this video is brought to you by Wix
whatsup wisecrack jared here the office
has been off the air for over six years
now but that hasn't stopped it from
being the most streamed show on netflix
or that is soon to be the formerly most
streamed show on netflix as NBC launches
their own streaming platform which will
hold our beloved IP hostage for a
monthly subscription fee while i love
the office the firmer surrounding it is
a little baffling few other shows are
watched day in and day out for more than
a decade the show is good some would say
it's very good some would also say it's
infinitely better than the second most
streamed show friends which tragically
taught millions of young uns
that you could move to New York as an
unemployed actor and live in a nice
apartment and do nothing all day
aside from lovable characters and great
jokes the office has something else in
its secret sauce both I mean actual BS
this isn't a value statement but rather
a reflection on the nonsense of our
characters work lives rather than
somehow having time to sit in a cafe all
day the office gives us characters who
also sit around doing nothing all day
but this time at a desk instead of a
couch today I'd like to argue that part
of the reason the office is so popular
is because it reflects on the prevalence
of complete and utter BS that has oozed
its way into every single crevice of our
professional lives and the economy as a
whole
so come with me as we go real deep
that's what she said yeah into the
office in this wisecrack addition on BS
jobs and as always spoilers ahead but
before we get into it I want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor Wix if
you're looking to step up your
professional game consider creating your
own website Wix has everything you need
to showcase your unique talent skill or
business everything is online nowadays
so if anyone searches your name you want
to make the best first impression when
we first partnered with Wix I made my
own website to promote my side hustle
voiceover work it was really fun to pick
out a design that reflected my
personality and customized my website if
you've never made a website before Wix
makes it so simple but thousands of
pre-designed templates that you can
customize without any coding experience
nest
Cerie if you're a longtime pro you can
also create your own masterpiece from
scratch with free web hosting automatic
mobile optimization and an SEO whiz
application your website will be ready
for anyone to view create your own
website for free today by going to
wix.com slash wisecrack or clicking here
and if you decide to upgrade you could
use the promo code wisecrack 15 to get
15% off all yearly plans and now back to
the show the office is a mockumentary
style series following the Scranton
Pennsylvania branch of a struggling
paper company Dunder Mifflin its helmed
by Michael Scott a manager whose antics
perpetually distract his workers from
actually doing work the worst thing
about prison was that was the Dementors
they were flying all over the place and
they were scary and then they come down
and they sucked the soul out of your
body and right after Steve Carrell
departure from the show he's replaced by
equally incompetent managers who
continued in Michael's tradition of
distraction and doling out of bad
metaphors Jim would you prefer a nature
metaphor or a sexual medical God nature
on the surface the office is about
people who must deal with unsatisfying
jobs while they're made deeply
uncomfortable by their boss
it also mocks familiar office archetypes
the uptight accountant the chatterbox
the attractive receptionist the person
waiting for retirement the unlovable HR
rep the lovable dunce and that guy who
went to Cornell I went to Cornell never
heard of it it also speaks to the
anxieties about the changing American
economy if earlier generations had to
deal with closing factories as the
service economy grew in the 2000s people
had to deal with the effects of
digitisation ecommerce and the
consolidation of retailers into a
handful of competitors and here I think
the office speaks to the both possession
of the economy that's an academic term
by the way that is at least the argument
proposed by anthropologist David Graeber
who claims that BS jobs are
proliferating throughout the developed
world he defines a BS job as a form of
paid employment that is so completely
pointless unnecessary or pernicious that
even the employee cannot justify its
existence even though as part of the
conditions of employment the employee
feels obliged to pretend that this is
not the case
and this seems to be the crux of life at
dunder-mifflin sitting in useless
meetings bow body
bow body what is the first B stand for
what are we doing we're making acronyms
in a job that's nearing obsolescence
following the random BS directives of
your superiors we're throwing out the
entire playbook we're starting from
scratch we're implementing a brand new
system and trying desperately to find
meaning in it all do you find that your
life feels pointless now that nobody's
actually filming you anymore yes there
might be some debate whether the workers
of dunder-mifflin have jobs or both jobs
which is an important distinction a
table may just sucks
say getting paid minimum wage to scrub
the toilet bowls at Taco Bell but you
know someone's got to do it and I don't
mean to say that there isn't real work
being done at dunder-mifflin Oscar and
Angela seem to be actually competent
accountants who get people paid on time
the sales people sell and so on but the
office checks off many of Graeter's
boxes for a BS job many of its employees
are aware of the general pointlessness
of their work Dunder Mifflin can't
compete with the modern chance and
management is unwilling or unable to
adapt at any moment Dunder Mifflin could
close and their clients would simply get
their paper needs filled by the larger
more cost-effective chains and even at
the threat of being downsized much of
the day seems dedicated to nonsense
meetings to figure out what color
streamers should be there's green
something called flonkerton and office
romance with a few exceptions no one
seems to particularly like their job Jim
fills his time with distraction by
playing pranks on Dwight everyone has
called me Dwayne all day I think Jim
Halpert paid them too
he's often praised for being smart and
competent despite the fact he spends
most of his time scheming by the end of
the day my desk was about 2 feet closer
to the copier yeah I just moved it an
inch every time he went to the bathroom
and that's how he spent my entire day
that day in spite of this he has
repeatedly offered promotions Jim if you
want the job it'll be his number two Wow
like why
Pam spends her work time planning her
wedding and conspiring with Jim at one
point she even invents a job for herself
so she doesn't get fired I'm the office
administrator kevin is an accountant who
can barely do math they do not give me
much responsibility yet stuck around for
years because firing him would be
uncomfortable if anyone here can make a
case for Kevin staying on his merit
Dwight on the other hand revels in
bureaucracy often spending his time
obsessing over the rules once in a while
I'll take a long lunch a siesta time
thief
time thief fire him titles you'll be
reporting to me them on the contrary my
title has manager in it or inventing
pointless bureaucratic structures the
only possible assistant to my assistant
is me Gabe has a director title but
wields no power and he can't even fire
anyone in his book Graber often
documents people who mused that nobody
would notice care or be worse off if
their BS job disappeared perhaps there's
no better example of this than Andy when
he's manager who spends months away from
the office on a boat with his boss not
even noticing Wallace does know that
you've been gone for the last three
months I have no idea I don't know what
he knows or doesn't know not only just
everyone do their job without him Rinka
knew they knew they seemed to excel at
it I couldn't be happier with the
numbers while the work at Dunder Mifflin
may be some combination of real work
work and [ __ ] work the whole idea
that Dunder Mifflin is a parasite on the
economy is raised as Michael explains
his job to children when asked if Dunder
Mifflin cuts and dies their own paper
Michael responds the paper is sent to us
cut and died from a paper manufacturer
and then we sell it to a business for
more than we paid for it to which the
children point out how superfluous and
possibly immoral his businesses why
doesn't the samel just sell the paper
directly to people you're describing
Office Depot and they're kind of running
us out of business the paradox of BS
jobs is that a free-market promises to
eliminate such waste if a job was truly
pointless he notes market pressures
would theoretically
of course Dunder Mifflin is subject to
these exact pressures as employees are
laid off in addition to severance and
everything I want to give you this gift
certificate to Chili's branches are
merged and the entire company is sold
and sold again it is from sare our new
owner but throughout it all
Scranton succeeds in spite of them never
doing much work the branch is riddled
with inefficiency not only in its
managers but in accountants who can't do
their job a guy who can't even remember
what his job title is only what do I do
here I should written it down clause
something and an HR rep who isn't
allowed to do his actual job
not now Toby my god oftentimes according
to graver BS jobs might have a small
amount of real work but culturally we're
expected to show up at the office for 40
hours a week so a whole culture of
looking busy and managers making up
pointless tasks fills up that time
employees often publicly declare their
jobs are truly of real importance if
only because they'd be unable to pay
rent without it there's a general sense
Graber argues that if you're not
suffering at your job then it's not
worth compensating fairly so instead of
optimizing efficiency we've begun to
optimize suffering when you can't prove
you're worthy of your paycheck with your
output the second best proof is your
misery
so to enforce this cultural norm we hire
more useless people who exist to make
sure people who have nothing to do can
look busy
Michael perhaps unwittingly is the best
example of this the office will likely
run fine without him and if anything his
behavior seems to be an impediment to
productivity he's convinced himself that
his actual job is to break up the
monotony of work for the well-being of
his staff at one point he spends an
entire day trying to come up with a
funny joke for Meredith's birthday card
this is from Michael Meredith let's hope
the only downsizing that happens to you
is that someone downsizes your age but
even that job function doesn't take much
time as we learn when pam is asked to
document what he does all day Michael
feigns busyness when it can
or when it can get him out of doing his
actual job duties I'm in my office I am
swamped I have worked up to my ears and
busy busy busy busy can't step away I
just wanted to check in for Graber
pointless jobs aren't just wasteful
they're incredibly harmful to our psyche
he documents people who dealt with
depression anxiety and guilt for the
fact that they were paid more or less to
do nothing this by the way is not just a
government work problem as it extends
well into the private sector even when
some employees took three hour lunches
traveled on the company's dime and
pursue their own projects they were
deeply unhappy rather Graber says people
derive pleasure at quote being the cause
that is having an effect on the world
even in a small way pointless jobs rob
us of that pleasure Graber
invokes Dostoevsky who while serving
time in exile at a Siberian prison camp
developed the theory that the worst
torture one could possibly devise would
be to force someone to endlessly perform
an obviously pointless task of course
many of the employees of Dunder Mifflin
are forever thwarted from being the
cause
whether by managers bureaucracy or just
the inanity of the task at hand
much of the show focuses on the
characters response to their pointless
professional lives
in some cases that response is them
becoming the cause in some other way
Jim is bored with his job and admits
that he'd killed himself if paper became
his career well if this were my career
I'd have to throw myself in front of a
train so he experiences agency through
his pranks and revels in being the cause
of Dwight's suffering pam has similar
feelings noting I don't think it would
be the worst thing if they let me go
because then I might I just I don't
think it's many little girls dream to be
a receptionist but they're able to cope
with distraction and eventually love and
family Stanley gets by with the hope of
retirement where he can carve wooden
birds all day also pretzel day I wake up
every morning and a big that's too small
driving my daughter to a school that's
too expensive and then I go to work to a
job for which I get paid too little but
on pretzel day
well I like pretzel day and when the
branch almost closes he's elated Oscar
ends the show running for state Senate a
role in which he could theoretically
produce change and even Kevin seems to
be pretty happy running a bar where he
can competently bring his guests joy and
not be a deadweight Michael meanwhile
denies the superfluous nature of his job
by convincing himself of its paramount
importance but his complete hatred of
Toby seems to be because he infringes on
his ability to be the cause in his own
office maybe you still can't make fun of
people for race or gender or sexual
orientation
look who let the lemonhead into the room
you were a waste of life and you should
give up of course his goal is to be
loved and respected his non-stop
narcissism and demands for attention are
explained by his lonesome childhood I
want to be married enhan read kids so I
can have a hundred friends and no one
can say no to being my friend that need
is finally satisfied by quitting his job
to live with Holly but before then he
often grasp desperately a meaning by
Framing his job in grandiose terms does
that make me their doctor yes and
emulating what he deems important and
worthy of respect
whether that's invoking a corporate
slogan I live by another role just do it
Nike directing a film dispensing wisdom
Lincoln once said that if you're a
racist I will attack you with the North
likening himself to other celebrities
it's Britney or my all-time favorite
when he attributed an inspirational
quote to both himself and Wayne Gretzky
that the show is presented like a
documentary only seems to further this
point Michael Scott is posturing for the
cameras to sell himself as an admired
thoughtful leader would I rather be
feared or loved easy both I want people
to be afraid of how much they love me
Dwight on the other hand embraces the
inanity and clings to pomp and
circumstance this all serves his warped
view of being the cause despite having a
successful beet farm which is
of real work he fixates on bureaucratic
titles effective immediately I am
promoting you from assistant to the
regional manager to assistant regional
manager
and the appearance of authority he
revels in absurd office politics and
spends most of the early seasons
ingratiating himself with Michael his
ultimate goal seems to be becoming a
kind of petty dictator where he can
finally have the ultimate say in his
life there's a lot of things that can
explain the offices success its cast its
jokes plus that quality of working
really well as ambience but I think
another big reason is just how common
both jobs are in 2013 the year the
office ended its run a Harvard Business
Review survey found that half of the
12,000 professionals asked felt that
their job had no meaning and
significance another poll found that 37
percent of British workers thought that
their jobs were utterly useless Kramer
says part of the reason they continue to
exist is because it seems so
antithetical to the nature of capitalism
for them to exist after all how could a
market economy not optimize these jobs
away societally we don't want to admit
that such a thing could be possible the
Soviet Union famously invented jobs so
that everyone could be employed and for
Graber we have somehow managed to do
something similar another reason BS jobs
are spreading graver theorizes is the
rise of the service economy while the
numbers of waiters barbers sales clerks
and so on that we traditionally
associate with service work remains
steady over time the rest of the service
economy has boomed that boom came from
administrators consultants clerical and
accounting staff IT professionals etc
it's not that all these jobs are BS but
they happen to be in a sector where bs
proliferate s-- we can break down these
BS jobs into several helpful categories
this includes flunkies employees who
exist solely to justify a manager's
position or inflate their prestige goons
who exist solely because other companies
are doing it think legal or marketing
departments duck tapirs who simply clean
up the mess of inefficient systems
I am the toilet of this office i flush
away annoying problems so others can
keep their hands clean box takers who
exist solely to verify that some other
actual work is being done that is not
actually being done and task masters who
create [ __ ] perk for other both
employees to do as a company that
doesn't actually make paper
dunder-mifflin exists squarely in this
service economy so much so that they
justify their higher prices in customer
service and Michael's own stated goal is
to hire people good manager doesn't fire
people he hires people inspires people
not necessarily because it's the sign of
a growing business but because his own
need to be loved is met by creating a
pseudo family I feel like all my kids
grew up and then they married each other
another reason the office may resonate
is because most of our characters do
successfully cope if we spend most of
our time looking busy the office is an
escapist fantasy where people won't get
fired for only working a minimal amount
of the workday and by the finale they've
all managed to endure the BS either by
finding love or simply leaving and maybe
that's all we can hope for in our lives
finding a better job or at least having
a domestic life that makes us happy
enough to not care but what do you think
wisecrack have you ever worked a BS job
and did the office help put your misery
in context let us know what you think in
the comments thanks to all our patrons
who support the channel and our podcasts
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and before you go I want to give
a shout out to Robbie Robbie used Wix to
create a portfolio for his animations
the website is really easy to navigate
showcases some really awesome videos and
makes it easy to get in touch it's been
really cool to see what our viewers are
up to and I have loved seeing all your
submissions right now you can create
your own website for free by going to
Wix comm / wisecrack and if you decide
to upgrade like Robbie you can use the
promo code wisecrack 15 for 15% off all
yearly plans and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]